yeah thanks so much Kover new subs are
Patti Houma Japan 95 Isaac 75 super
mingle - - once super mingle was
watching yesterday
and ctrl f RK not sure what that means
but welcome everyone to being a sub okay
i'm playing my main rapper tour I'll
play it time on the open Sicilian c7 a
control freak or control fork haha two
interesting possibilities yeah I'll take
with pawn and strengthening the center I
want to play d5 and d5 is a typical
break in the center why can i can take
or leave the tension can't push just yet
yeah challenge to anything that's
considered blitz on me chess I want to
have time to get through like a number
of games f3 is questionable it's a
little bit weakening to this diagonal
now white can castle and can't play
Bishop e3 either
okay nice to see a lot of people are
setting their their Li chest names to be
identified as a sub plate rook b8 trying
to tie down the bishop to defending this
pawn yeah so if you use the Li chest
command successfully your name should
appear purple
good job Batman chess good job Thomas
Princeton welcome back Thomas well maybe
it got deleted yeah maybe you have to do
it like every month I forget how it
works the banana is back toxic banana
party I've this this is a time on of
slow-motion replay or fast motion replay
it's a pleasant time on earth my Center
a nice development this bishops kind of
sad
maybe someday it will come to life like
castling the e5 white wants to do this
but runs into d4 but does that win a
piece is d4 there is a knight a for the
counter-attack and then there's a
counter counter-attack but then there's
a defense
yeah I don't think I'm winning material
here it seems like I should be but I'm
not seeing it takes takes there's
Queenie five the Queenie 5 is
interesting I think I'll play Queen a5
feel like this creates the most pressure
official takes e5 then Queen takes c3
and then triple fork
what do you say to offer a draw and in
international tournaments oh if the
pointer doesn't speak English this has
happened to me before where I do this
like I'll make my move do this and then
hit the clock sign language I mean you
can also say draw because pretty much
everyone understands that not sure if I
know how to say draw in any other
language in Russian Russian its
Nietzsche I think or something Nietzsche
yeah Hotch Anita means I want draw
yeah so I think why it's okay why I
played the best man was gonna say Bishop
d2 it's probably the only move now I
have Bishop d4 or Bishop b4 or d4
probably not Bishop d4 Bishop b4 yeah
applying pressure White's taking a lot
of time
that's only move 12
can you just pick up your king and go
home that's possible
that's a peaceful approach but not every
chess game is peaceful
hmm I was a nice sip of tea also free
pieces or one free piece wise pilgrim
thanks for subbing I'm brand new sub and
weights about to flag Oh another free
piece this battery was so strong okay
tough game relative impacts I can give
you a few pointers so what I'll do is
I'm gonna copy the URL and then go to my
study what happened to my study study
subscriber challenges and then paste
this I'll make sure to have this open
all the time
dobe chapter 1 ok so this is the first
game of the stream I was black whoa
what's going on here is weird so first
things first after Queen c7 I don't
recommend taking as it strengthens the
Center for black there's a number of
moves like can play here Bishop III is a
mainline and then after a six white can
decide between usually this this Queen
f3 has been trying to eat lately
there's another line and there's so many
lines against time on the line that I
would probably recommend if you're not
like at all
knowledgeable is g3 I think this is one
of the safest lines and it's also kind
of annoying to deal with even at higher
levels white spy on this Bishop g2
castling Bishop e3 sometimes might be
three and white has a pleasant position
more space with the e4 pawn this is
really weird occasion it's like it's not
registering the move but now it is so
yeah instead of f3 White Castle rook e1
f3 was a bit more damaging than it was
useful
I think b3 was fine I was thinking
Bishop b2 here Bishop b2 could be
interesting then later like this and
this just leave the King in the center
and then yeah final final moment
Queen e3 was a the biggest blunder a
move like night a4 keeps white alive
that's probably not that bad I would I
think I have to trade here take stakes
and then it would be a fight so okay
good game relative impacts I'll play
another person I think the Batman chess
was the first to challenge
it's like e4 oh okay I'll play this game
but for future challenges challenge me
to blitz this is considered rapid okay
we have a French let's play a I'll play
the two Knights attack
it's a favorite opening of mine I still
have to remember to make a two Knights
attack video someone chimed in yesterday
just
constantly reminding me c5 is a move
that doesn't happen so often but it's
playable the the best approach is to do
this and then create a situation where
lack has an IQ p on d5 pawn stormtrooper
thanks for subbing for two months
wise pilgrim don't include the the
angular brackets just just a space and
then your elite chess username
let's wait there should be five thank
you
toxic banana party for telling people
what to do
so Bishop d7 looks like we need to
keeping some initiative this is
interesting so I could maybe you just
went along like I'll take and then I'll
trying to hold on to this pawn I have
Bishop e3 and b4 if necessary play
Bishop e3 first realizing Bishop e3
rookie eights and then maybe B for
rookie it could be strong actually
casting is a good move so Bishop e3
rotates a pin is annoying
B for a 5
hmm
actually considering a lion Bishop III
rukia castling queenside takes Knight
takes it looks fun let's do it I'm
playing a little bit greedy like I'm
just trying to hold on to material I
might be punished but we'll see what
happens
oh I should make toxic a mod even if his
name is toxic toxic I can spell the
whole thing yeah so this is slightly
multi-purpose I'm getting the King off
the x-ray vision my queen still kind of
a target but I'm I'm counter attacking
the D pawn so we'll see what black does
Anna party
I bought bananas yesterday I want to
make like a banana smoothie but they're
not toxic
hopefully Bishop takes e5 oh I could
sack my queen but that would be dubious
wait a minute take stakes just have to
make sure I'm not losing a piece I don't
think I am it's complicated
like three minor pieces are staring at
each other
and then we both have rooks aligned with
each other's Queen it's very high take
inducing but it's also from dowel worthy
yeah just looking at this position makes
my head hurt I think everything's okay
in many cases I I take the night with
check and it simplifies things in other
cases I backlink mates because blacks
King has no lift bank stuff men also
asad figuring things out so yeah if
you're challenging me and your name is
purple you figured things out gee cook
1729 thank you for two months or wait no
at tier 2 woah tier 2 for 3 months
feel free to challenge me maybe I should
have like a stipulation where two tier
two subs get more priority hmm I have
nothing like it's not built-in to keep
track of tier 2 or tier 3 even and just
only if you're a sub
what's your win-loss against Jerry I
could look that up but you have to guess
what it is
I guess people could look it up to a six
slightly unexpected thinking I can take
as I was saying I take with check if
Queen takes I win a piece right so pawn
takes well this looks pretty good for me
so idle beat chest off org I'll just
check on me chess we may have played on
ICC at some point in time that is
probably ages ago the chest network it's
chess on your score network well it's
Jerry's name
I'm trying to find his name but the two
names I thought are not working okay
Shoji takes what's his you should move
the bishop
I could take oh its chest - Network okay
I'll try that let's think takes takes I
[Music]
mean I'm already up upon looking for
ways to to capitalize or just to
simplify
yeah I should escape the pin this could
be a tricky move
I'll do this getting out of the pin
threatening the bishop also threatening
queen g4 with the fork and if takes I
guess I have to take back and the
Knights still pinned all blocks under
some pressure okay so I brought up
Gerry's profile to check my score I have
to go here and then I think here well
just happened hey
22:23 I think we play the mix of like
okay it's mostly bullets we've played
some blitz maybe we played 43 times on
me chess whoa Belgium novice awhile
since I last cheers I'm making up for it
thanks so much Belgian novice I
appreciate that also thank you Belgian
novice I don't know if I mention this
but I met Belgian novice in person and
Belgian novice gave me Belgian
chocolates and they were delicious so
thank you for that as well and thank you
to my opponent for allowing queen g4 and
now I'm winning a queen and now it's
time to try and finish things off in
smooth fashion
hmm plea for the palms defended in the
night's attacks Knights tied down to
that six pawn
so I'm either winning the night or the
pawn if I win the pawn that'll be closer
to me Thomas saying Grandmaster gari
helped me become an affiliates
here on twitch wait Thomas do you stream
to as if you're a twitch affiliates that
means you've been streaming for at least
a few weeks have to catch your extreme
okay let's win the night I'll try and
give a shout out at some points sure all
been chefs welcome back Schrauben chefs
I got your message I'm in the process of
replying to it but thanks so much for
for reaching out oh let's play Queen age
six okay take this now I have a past
each pawn so if I want to be really lazy
all like I'll just March the pawn up but
okay no need for me it is coming
[Music]
at which affiliates is like the first
step in like monetizing your twitch
accounts where you can you can accept
subs and bits okay Batman chess GG I'll
put this in the study as well oh except
I use the tab so I mean egos challenges
okay trying to think what recommendation
to give I honestly don't recommend c5 in
this position there's other moves back
and play d4 is a move or Knight f6 but
what happened the game I guess it was
playable and then I think this was a
really key position I don't think a6 was
the best move I mean I could be very
lazy and turn on stockfish
yeah I'm gonna be lazy let's see if
stockfish finds anything for black
weights just stuff up on Bishop c6 it's
a hard move to play so it unleashes more
more pressure along the D file so if we
go back any improvements I think it was
already difficult yeah so this is why
I'd probably recommend don't play c5
like none of 69.6 for d4 like one of
those moves I do not consider myself a
chess prodigy oh wait let me open a new
tab yeah there we go and let's play to
play your hypnotic voices if an Evelyn
give to the insomniacs among us well
thanks for that comment supersymmetry 91
don't think anyone has ever told me that
before
alright playing w v DK 9 out of 6 okay
let's play a Budapest
I've been playing the Budapest so much
lately it's just becoming a little bit
redundant but it's fun I'm drinking this
is tea the brand is called stash it's um
some kind of berry I think it's called
us acai berry caffeine free herbal tea
it's good
Aman Hamilton was in town about a month
ago and he just ordered like so much tea
for the apartment so now we're just
drowning and tea it's great I'm pretty
sure that's how you pronounce acai it's
spelled a CAI
if there's a different better
pronunciation let me know
Oh Belgian novelist had this exact
position over the board two days ago
pretty sure I had this exact position
earlier today and like a bullet game but
opponent actually earlier today my
opponent played Nate and d2 which was
interesting
so I've I mean I've had the same sort of
position many times where the idea is to
play this this and then eventually
checkmate mainly with the arrows
is a pronounced Sakai I guess it could
be let's play a five a common mistake is
why playing a three to prepare B for
where then a five is basically a free
tempo for black so it prevents before
and continues with this plan a for I
think a four gives me a free tempo as
well I think white was maybe trying to
stop me from playing a four okay the
rook lifts it's a nice migration from
AAA to h6 and just two moves it's a soft
C okay good to know
nice to have some confirmation so I have
18 pending challenges I'm likely going
in order in terms of subs so if you
haven't turned your name purple there's
still time to do so
it takes Queen h4
okay I mean this is a relatively forcing
line takes takes Queen h4 h 3 and then
d6 so I think Bishop takes H 3 let's do
it actually looking at this move it kind
of almost works if takes takes takes
king h1 that's made into after this this
and then this the promised work f2 so
I'll go with this on d6 so everything
kind of playing a role like all the
pieces directed at the King side in some
way or another are you following the
fishery random Chess Championship at all
I've I tuned in for like 2 or 3 minutes
I saw Magnus convert this Bishop versus
rook ending and that's that's extent of
me following it
I heard yasser soothing voice and so
Pico and Danny wrench but I've it's hard
for me to like consume so much content
there's a balance of creating content
there's a balance of doing other things
I was busy making soup earlier Wow we
need to soak we need to I think runs
into this wait should I double check now
let's just be intuitive I think the
problem for a why does after take stakes
I'm threatening both queen h2 and also
orc g6 what kind of soup I actually I've
made an Instagram story I'm pretty sure
I posted it it was don't even know like
what you call it it was cauliflower soup
it's cauliflower onion garlic
toasted almonds I just found it on
YouTube it's pretty simple
way what napal tried to castle moving
his rook first way that's really strange
oh but if it's Fisher random I guess
that's possible because it's confusing
that's still funny a good game tough
game for my opponents I'll paste this
into the study oh no not that
here we go new chapter I'll show I'll
use this opportunity to show one
recommendation for white against the
Budapest
I think the first mistake was a four
maybe better would be like bring the
knight to either a three or even to e4
but if we go back I can show what I
would play if I'm playing against a
budapest and it starts with actually
starts with Bishop d2 and this will be a
trap if black plays naturally for like
three moves and light will win a piece
so the trap is okay black usually takes
takes takes and now Bishop c3 so you
align your bishop nicely with the
undefended Knight undefended pawn now it
looks very natural for Locke to play d6
here and I first discovered this by
walking into it in some litzer Bullock
game actually walked into it twice
before I actually went back and looked
it up but I played d6 thinking that the
Queen trade like takes takes takes takes
is very fine for black which it is black
has a bishop pair but after d6 white to
move and win a piece by force
I'll let the chats take some time
which way would you recommend learning
opening slash opening ideas apart from
books playing playing and then saving
your your games to elite just study even
saving your openings to elite chess
study and like going back using opening
explorer I mean me chess has so many
great built-in tools all for free can
you stock fish also chasuble chasuble is
becoming very popular these days like
these more kind of interactive books oh
we have F foreign before being the main
suggestions F for is not as good it's a
bit weakening to III it also doesn't win
a piece might win a pawn but for example
like here even like c6 takes rook G 8
blocks getting some comp
there's some funny line Bishop here here
g3 and then takes it could get really
weird but okay the best move is before
before wins apiece it's incredible like
block did what you normally should do in
the Budapest and is now getting punished
promote exclam because after Bishop e6
there's c5 and bishops trapped this pawn
is kind of tied down defending the
Knights and yeah it just wins a piece so
now I'm curious if I continue to play
the Budapest consistently how many
people will actually try this against me
okay
a new game let's play pawn masseur
sounds like my opponent will try and
massage my pawns ooh we have a I feel
like if I take my opponent might play
Stafford gambit I'm gonna play Bishop c4
here it's interesting approach so then
that after takes we have a reverse
Stafford gambit and I got in Bishop c4 I
was kind of an extra tempo and block has
already walked into one of the main
traps
or the arbiter intervened maiden empo
just move the rook yeah that makes sense
oh he made an official complaint and
they replayed the game what I wonder if
like the rules aren't like so so
specific for Fisher random where maybe
his complaint was actually valid is this
an American or English staffer gambit
it's a chess staffer gambit not sure of
the nationality or the roots this
actually might have a different name
like starting in this position we chess
probably knows I'll check it afterwards
but yeah it's not so comfortable for
luck I've had this position from the
reverse perspective with a move like 96
included okay so the general rule is to
take with a knight and to keep the
lights where'd bishop because the bishop
can very be very dominant especially on
e6 and especially without black having
the light squared bishop anymore
if the Queen attacks it I won't move the
bishop at all just reinforced defending
also preparing bishop at five around
Bishop g5 a sinking head queen g6 Bishop
f5 there's also some idea if knight c6
Bishop g7 I'll put the Queen put the
Queen here
yeah so the Queen and Bishop they're
still having a nice relationship even if
it's a long-distance relationship g5l
it's got some g5 emotes for my opponents
the first move that comes to mind is
Bishop c8 because how does black defend
this that would be so nice if it works
it might work I should see it I just
want a fianchetto in my opponent's
territory I guess I'll find out what
black will do here because I you I
sometimes have this position with night
here included and then Bishop c8
wouldn't be so threatening see Bishop c8
would lose to g4 yeah the problem is if
the knight develops I I take and I fork
the rook and Knight
so that's expected let's save the queen
threatening this now
okay I think I'm I'm actually only
winning a pawn if black plays the best
move but it'll still be nice yeah this
is the best move whoa
I think that's a mistake because Queen
b5 check this was an attack but this is
a counter attack and now the rook is
still hanging
the Albee of a rook
oh the Kinect for emotes I have so many
things I have a to-do list I'll add
Kinect for emotes to my to-do list
[Music]
if I can get this app to work okay
Connect four ooh sneaky move oh let's
just take email okay
[Music]
how come I'm not a GM I also have I have
another thing on my to-do list an FAQ
page which I feel like I desperately
need to just answer the frequently asked
questions let me find what I wrote I was
on the flight last week from Taiwan
actually it was South Korea to Chicago
my layover it was in South Korea and I
was born on the plane so I started
writing an FAQ list that's Castle I
would be very thrilled if black takes up
on because I my file opens and the very
first thing on this list is when will
you become a GM or why are you not a GM
okay I always play King v1 here it is
there's my answer not sure if that will
focus maybe not what to do
I'll tap the sea pong this is one of the
main weaknesses there's not too many
ways for black to defend its 96 I I'm
happy to trade yeah let's take if night
here I'll play this a jayegi tea or is
it jg t thanks for subbing with twitch
prime okay so I'm attacking the night
the pawn I'll take the pawn first ok GG
um yeah so there is one thing I wanted
to check also sworn wait till I lose a
study again I think I lost the study
[Music]
there we go ok so this is the fourth
game of the stream the first thing I
wanted to check is a name of this oh
that you're a soft camping really no
this is the Bowden kazurinsky gambit and
as far as I know a block has to be like
super super careful from this position I
think f6 is a main move but it gets
really weird because I'm not h4
threatening this I think there's some
theory most of masters database g6 and
then at 4 like if you're gonna play this
as black you have to be very well
prepared so I can recommend something
simple after Knight c3 and it's a move
that I've I played in the past as black
in this position is just Knight f6 it
looks slow but the idea is to play d5
and this comes with tempo against
submission so after Knight takes e5 d5
Black's completely fine budget t6 comes
with tempo castling easier position to
play but yeah after Knight g5 is it was
pretty fun as nice to have this Bishop
c8 moved to haven't had something like
this in a while but yeah the the line
with f6 is basically stock fishes top
choice and I think it's good if you like
if you know it inside and out but it's
not easy to to fully understand okay
let's play like a leaf 3 oh maybe like a
leaf is just floating in the wind so as
online okay let's play let's play d5
this time that's something a bit
different
no Budapest to this game oh I was gonna
answer the question why am I not a GM
it's not the top priority of mine there
is a lot of work that goes into getting
the GM title even when you're an IM like
it would take at least a couple years of
like full devotion to the game to
studying and to playing and to play in
like GM norm tournaments i would have to
travel like more than I do now which
would be a lot and I want to devote more
time to like teaching and online content
but if I ever do become a GM I do own
the domain name GN rosen.com
so just in case a c5 I wanted to play
Cambridge Springs but that won't happen
let's play b6 should be six before
I'll do it usually with the structure
the two main ideas for black are either
be six or a five I'm looking at before
takes takes Queen a five just keeping
initiative when will you play blindfold
that's another thing I haven't done in a
while
I lost my blindfold it was really tragic
because I bought this like really nice
blindfold on Amazon they call it a
sleeping mask it's like nice kind of
padded I left it on the airplane in like
on my way to San Francisco a few weeks
ago then I bought another blindfold in
Singapore and I lost that one I left it
at like an air B&B so a new one arrives
yesterday actually whoa this is a fork
so I think my goal is to not travel with
something that I can easily lose and the
new one will be sufficient to to use for
mindful chess I still have the thing
like to take my boosts okay I have to
take with pawn the first thing that
comes to mind is this but doesn't quite
work does this I just lose two pieces
this pawns attacked twice and not
defended at all because this Knights
pinned
so I'll play h6 this is a tricky move
magining takes takes takes takes takes
takes takes and then Queen h4 I win back
the pawn a lot of takes yeah that's
happening and I'm I'm up a piece because
I had the fork earlier yeah this can be
pre moved are you more proud to have the
same name as Eric Hanson or Eric Clapton
that's a deep question if you rearrange
the letters and Eric Clapton you get
narcoleptic so probably Eric Hanson
let's take okay we're gonna have some
endgame trading a lot of stuff by Ewa
Bishop I also have more time and there's
no increments so most likely late low
flag
always playoff six second most likely
maybe I can orchestrate some mates but
it's not easy start with this
okay getting closer oh this is very
close to meet play this move if I play
here then it's White's meeting me okay
nice game like a leaf and bring this
game into the study as well let's go
back this way
I think the first mistake was c5 not the
type of move white should usually play I
can give a couple of recommendations so
the main move is III and then I would
play Cambridge Springs so if you run
into Cambridge Springs the best was 92
or Bishop takes off 6 or takes as a few
different moves
honestly the move I can recommend is
just taking first relieving a little bit
of tension sure takes back and then you
you do your normal stuff but the blunder
in the game was allowing efore so was
castling white should take here after it
takes it's not that bad like takes takes
some trades it would be a fights okay
new game oh let me start a new game from
this tab ok playing Thomas shout out to
Tom Steenson who's a streamer still have
to watch his stream what to play well if
I'm not played against Thomas I'll play
some some variation of Sicilian
Oh like a leaf in the chat saying thank
you for the game was way excited playing
against you silly mistake yeah it
happens
it was Smith Morra okay I'll play
against the Smith Morra up upon hmm just
trying to remember my my prep what's the
most evil thing you've done that's um
that's an evil question if you saw my
stream my last day or two just so many
dirty flags a lot of evilness
in those games what's the line here
I play a six who do I play this also
this is a sermon recommendation I should
start with this
I know taking runs into a lot of trouble
after it takes and Rookie one I believe
I know a sermon is booked up at least
like ten more moves from this point
wait 96 I thought Bishop f4 is usually
played first okay I'll take was I
haven't had to play a six the main line
was Bishop f4 a six so in some sense I
have an extra tempo to play b5 it looks
like a weird position
this is pawn on d6 my queen on b8 maybe
I'll Castle Oh Castle looks natural like
a leaf thanks for the bits
thanks again three thanks for the game
have you ever tried rock climbing I've
done rock climbing like a gym where they
have the things on the wall and you
climb them in real life maybe I mean
I've climbed like a rock but not
professionally Oh first bits ever hey
you got the the cheer 100 bit badge very
nice question from the ghost hi Erik we
all know you love the London but do you
hate any opening not like it's hard to
play or uncomfortable but just dislike
it as many people do with a London for
being too boring I mean I don't like
just personally I don't like the green
falender neither because just the theory
scares me but I'm pretty open to two
openings
trying to think like even exchange
French so I like oak I like the fact
that there's openings with like
particular like reputations where
sometimes you can disprove the
reputation or find ideas that don't
really reflect the style of opening okay
none of six I think makes most sense I
was considering 95 but night would be
awkward there like with London might
have a boring solid reputation but
there's so many lines where it's it's
sharp exciting trappy even like exchange
French as this like very dry reputation
thanks for making the comest content on
the internet and rose in life is good
thanks rofl axis but with exchange
French - there's some East recently I've
been looking into lines with a lot of
venom and fire okay let's play Knights
94 looks nice
hitting the bishop hitting the pawn I
was thinking about playing d5 that I
think that just would have helped white
play Bishop d3 can you do a stream of
you making soup I thought about it I
didn't want to do it today because it
was my first time like making it fresh
and doing this recipe but in the future
I think it would be doable I need to
like reconfigure the setup with the
webcam and mic I do have the story on
Instagram though you can check me out on
Instagram and see the step-by-step
process it's really just three or four
pictures but the final picture looks
nice I think everyone agrees with me
that I am Rosen should do a Minecraft
stream you can't just say that thinking
that I'll just trust you that everyone
agrees also I like I don't even know
what minecraft is I've heard of it I
wouldn't know how to like start a game
or even stream it well I need an Xbox I
feel like I wouldn't even have like some
kind of Xbox or GameCube maybe just too
complicated I could do minesweeper
though minesweeper would be fun
I think nakamora stream minesweeper at
some point in time okay I want to take
the pawn that like to save my night
first at 5:00
and I think this is reasonable in the
ponds a goner I'm slow to develop like
these pieces need to developing but
it'll happen eventually
yeah I did catch a glimpse of Djoser's
lasagna stream it was actually quite a
nice setup how frequently are you
recognized outside of chess events in
real life outside of chess events I mean
I'm recognized a lot like at chess
events even like internationally while
the people requesting photos and
autographs it's pretty cool outside of
chess events I think it's only happened
twice once was in Chiang Mai I was at a
cafe and someone like sitting nearby
just recognized me from YouTube another
time was in San Francisco I walked out
of a cafe and it was impressive someone
like came running from across the
streets saying that he like watches my
London videos okay let's play e5 going
for a for e for looks nice Queen e5
coming
I'm up two ponds the first pond was a
gambit the second pond was lights almost
invincible pond but it went a little too
deep
so after this game I'll have to point
Thomas to the last room in preparation
as I played a sermon in the sign-in it
like it's actually very dangerous for
black and I would be scared to play it
against a sermon or against anyone who
studied it like farily what's the
maximum weight you've lifted in gym I
don't do like the deadlift or beasley
good to see you welcome back thanks
again for subbing f4 is a move but it
looks like a free pawn white scam
betting so many pawns
yeah the work outside you usually
require dumbbells so max I use or it's
like maybe 25 to 30 pounds I do a lot
more cardio than you do a mix of like
cardio lifting and growing a six looks
nice
[Music]
how much tees you usually drink in a day
[Music]
trying to think how much I've had I mean
this is my first pot of the day this
will probably be like two to three cups
these pawns are so majestic finally
developing the bishop I have a London
Fog tea latte earlier at Starbucks not
sure if that counts when I was about to
order it I almost said in London opening
but I caught myself
[Music]
I think on days where I stream I'll just
drink more tea but even on days I don't
stream it will be at least one to two
cups let's play actually let's defend
everything and be greedy
so covering a 6 there is increments also
this is rated I don't think I'll gain
any rating points from this but not
losing any either
ooh tricky so it's gonna win this but
this pawn is rolling
all right good game Thomas if we want to
yeah let's grab this link paste it as a
new chapter here so for any Smith Morra
players out there I mean this is a line
I've I recommend for black but I can
also like show how wide should play
first of all the I think the most
popular move or one of the most popular
Queeny two runs into a very interesting
idea Knight g4 and then there's a nice
trap I can see on me chess if I plays h3
just up there in terms the most popular
black wins a queen with this it's nice
just destruction those Knight takes d4
his mates
so Nyepi fives the best line so I assume
Thomas has uh I studied this actually
saying in the chat forgot to play Bishop
f4
yeah Bishop f4 is uh as a key move now
when it comes to remembering openings
it's important to just also understand
like the ideas you play Bishop f4 just
to defend the pawn and then to prepare
ninety-six but you should only play
ninety-six after black plays a6 so I
would have played a six here it takes
takes I think there's some trap like if
black plays b5 too early there's a
stockfish idea Bishop d5 where after
takes rook e1 likeit's like monster
compensation requires some further
analysis I I'm realizing here Knight f6
this all works because of rookie 7 it's
insane because s 7 is now almost
undefensible and if takes takes white
wins the queen so just goes to show like
some of the venom so I would have
castled and then I think each three yeah
when in doubt follow a sermon a sermon
is master of mayhem he might even have
like some games and database maybe not
and she surprised there's no games cuz
this is one of the most topical lines in
the Smith Mora and then 95 should be the
move yeah 95 takes takes
I thought I had a game against him maybe
it didn't make the database 98 um I
think the the best move for black after
95 is to play Knight b4o it can branch
out a lot though might be 4 you'll only
run into a flax like very well-prepared
a 98 is most natural or takes in that 90
units and then sock fish knows what's up
alright good game um let's continue I do
have to go at some points but I'll try
and get in a few more games of Sikkim
chess I feel like we played recently at
some points in time as opponent still
here oh what's my favorite tea I like
the variety I was just in Taiwan and
that long tea was big incredible like
they grow tea and Taiwan saw some tea
farms if I'm shopping at Whole Foods
I like Egyptian licorice slightly sweet
no caffeine of Thomas taking off yeah
thanks for the game
I'll follow you let me follow you on
Twitch and that way I'll be notified
when you stream follow there we go
also shout-out to Thomas wait what just
happened Oh still waiting for a game
ok let's abort and let's play a new game
James face
always happy to try and support new
streamers I spell that right I hope I
spelled that right sometimes bad with
spelling ok mr. James face wait what why
did I say mister just James face ok um
it's yc5
[Music]
wait a minute Knight f3 another three I
can take you now three is a slight
mistake usually white should defend with
a pawn as if a piece lands in the center
all probably got initiative or at the
very least I'll have two Center pawns
play knight c6 maybe this isn't so bad
for whites I think my plan is this
attack b2 and prepare a five
Oh can someone post FAQ oh there you go
yeah the the command is sub challenge
and now nightbot gives instructions
okay so Bishop g7 being cuddling
preparing to fianchetto in my opponent's
territory Queen c2 let's um let's attack
the Queen it's always nice to develop
with attack like this attacked this
attacks maybe I'll have Queen 85 and
with Czech attacking the King just
looking at Queen eight for Queen 84 I
just take me to allow this and move over
our beasley you need to have a space
between leech s and your leech s
username try that one more time it's
like five looks nice
so what I'm doing for the stream is
taking challenges from subscribers so
just news will be next presumably
there you go and yeah if you correctly
did the movie chest commands and you
challenged me your name should appear
purple here let's play yeah let's play
d4 and e4 looks nice
so I'm fully developed usually like
after the opening like once you develop
you want to fight for different types of
advantages so I'm fighting for space
fighting for initiative looking for
targets to attack 9a for not sure what I
should be attacking I mean maybe D 3 D 3
and E 4 not sure how much that
accomplishes I could take a taking is
interesting I'm setting up a small trap
if Queen takes TAS I'll win upon the
intermediate move and after this I have
Queen a5 Sanchi forcing Knight c3 after
Knight c3 I think I'll play rook b8
again more developing with tempo yeah I
dunno gari um he started streaming
within the last month or two I think I
caught his first stream one of his first
streams was a collaboration with
Costilla coots key I've known gari for
years like we first played back when I
was like a teenager young teenager
before high school I think at some point
I'm sure we'll do a collaboration okay
this looks pretty promising
keeping initiative feels like every move
is like a capture or a threat so the
Queen's tied down to defending the
bishop and doesn't have too many squares
the moves here it there's a fork most
here I attack it again my queen defends
the row
there's actually no good way to
counter-attack this rook these squares
are off-limits
see look we only has one squares at
three
it's almost trapped queenie three runs
into the fork oh wait a minute
so if takes takes thankfully i have not
a five over then queen c1 over than this
okay everything works out chess gods are
on my side let's take this weight about
to flag tough game yeah I'll probably
play the London let me show what should
have been played we go add a new chapter
I think I've managed to put all the
games in the stream in a study if I
forgots someone can let me know but yeah
from whites perspective whenever the C
pawn challenge is a D pawn usually white
should play III know there's some
argument for c3 but the idea is with the
structure you'll put the pawn on c3
you'll do the typical London setup and
whites actually happy to have the half
of an e file because after castling a
rook to e1 is a nice piece to have and
it's a bit more solid than defending
with the night and then capturing within
lanes because what ended up happening
was I had I had a bit more central space
with a pawn here and white didn't have a
center pawn on the fourth ring now this
actually reminded me of a trap there's a
different approach let's say here here
c5 like could go wrong here same idea
playing Knight f3 and after it takes
takes
black to move and win material it's a
relatively basic tactic but all that the
twitchchat
try and find it black to move when a
piece by force
[Music]
also next in line will be lv n 2k oh
this is interesting we have two
suggestions for Queen a five and two
suggestions for a five only one of these
moves is working when a five does not
work because of multiple reasons the
intention is good like you want to play
e5 next and fork the problem is okay
Bishop t2 defends even Knight c3 e5 and
night b3 why it's not losing material so
play e5 first works because if Bishop
takes e5 then Queen a five nice little
fork followed by another fork so okay
hopefully there's some lessons to take
away from from that game wait where did
the opponent go Oh lv n 2k it was purple
before oh that that was a little bit
weird took a moment there okay let's
play a scandi team scan d i'll play play
knife six
I have a lot of options here I could
play Bishop g4 I think I'll play Bishop
g4 just delaying capturing the pond
I'll see if white wants to defend it
this could turn into a gambit if I play
c4 I'm using whatever Mouse this is it's
a Logitech something gamer mouse it's a
chess brown mouse so I'm not entirely
sure what the exact brand is but it's
nice house a nice fuel hasn't broke yet
I'm very happy to play e5 lights 92 is a
little bit passive usually what Knight
c3 should be played a Logitech g40 too
what's your favorite tea I answered that
just a few minutes ago or at least tried
to answer it have to add that to my FAQ
list okay this is reasonable for white
and Bishop g2 good move
you know Castle queenside I'll make it
sharp I'm allowing light some discovery
but in most cases of the visible hang
well Olivia Lucas wants to see me
playing accelerated dragon Oh
hyperaccelerated dragon I'll keep that
in mind let's play this checking the
king
if c3 I entered meso Bishop takes d3
Bishop d2 do I want to trade I think I
do as I'm keeping initiative this is a
move just applying pressure do you ever
like wait do you like slash ever play
variants on me chess not too often at
least recently lost like there's a big
tournament like the leech has Fisher
random title arena I would I would play
but apart from that really not too often
I think I'd probably gone through some
phases where all I'll play like [ __ ] in
her crazy house but it's been a while I
take here you can also take here whoo
let's
I mean both moves look good let's take
here first it's more direct but
essentially the same idea take on d3
work the Queen and the Knights there's
some messiness because white could maybe
counter-attack your goodness and go
after this but everything should be okay
there's actually a funny line here here
here and then mate King is a bit
stranded in the center oh this is
interesting
so if I take I'll be up to pawns in the
end and also consider taking here or
even this move but I'm temporarily down
in peace
so let's win it back try and get the
Knight to f4 but II five s hanging okay
I'll play f6 solid move
[Music]
okay I'm just setting up a trap to do
this
doesn't win material but it'll be
pleasant I want to take and play NightA
for assuming rookie ones played will you
ever play drops again it's another thing
like I have a lot of things on my to-do
list but if I'm reminded enough times
I'll probably do it weights oh there's
no increments oh wow
forgot to look at the time control I
like that
the time warning noise is nice made me
alerts just have to keep the time
advantage like to construct some meeting
idea check let's move comic maybe all
right good game I'll be on - okay can
paste this into the study Oh
[Music]
a lot of the advice I've been giving is
like opening advice it's just the
easiest like sort of quick feedback I
gave a lecture for a st. Louis chess
club where I mentioned like some
recommendation against this like from
whites perspective amateur opening
gambit you find this copy and if I add
this to the study yeah
I'll share the study link in the chat as
well people want to like browse through
these games and this should play within
the study but there's at some point
maybe later
yeah I recommend whoops whoa I pressed F
trying to flip the board oh that's weird
you flip the board here I recommend
bishop here and in the video I share I
share a crazy line where White Sox
exchange but I think like objectively
this is one of the best ways to play for
whites because white defends upon and
then black has to work to win it back
and in many cases even if black wins it
back like gets some advantage
[Music]
oh we have Sikkim chess returning okay
I'll play some chess I think what I'll
do is I'll play Joel Pan and then
that'll be it so sorry to everyone else
challenging me let's play e4 this game
who do I be aggressive let's be
aggressive I'll play Smith Maura have
some fun inspired by the master of
mayhem
maybe we'll see the same line hey this
is what I played against uh Thomas over
a six
okay sixes new move for me telling my
opponents might be prepared
hmm
yeah I'll admit that I'm not
knowledgeable about this position
terminator 100 bonus 10 please do a
stream playing variants like antique
chest and crazy house could be
interesting well thanks for the bits
taking Ches offering me some motivation
I think maybe I'll do a strawpoll we're
all I'll have like different stream
ideas
I'll let the viewers decide ie v u5 d5
Queeny choose a move play Queen e2 in my
plan is just to go for not in a media
kill but just like consistent
development rook t1 coming and just play
the position pretend that I'm not dalla
pong okay can i play e5 and now me 5 we
trade stuff throw in Bishop c2 play e5
opening the D file trying to get some
attack block stole up a pawn but okay I
have a bit more activity rooks are happy
not sure if I have a threat here I
should host a Halloween gamete arena on
Halloween that could be cool can i host
a a thematic arena imagine it's possible
I wouldn't be surprised if Lee chest
like has something like that though that
they're doing so if they're doing it
I'll probably just join it hmm yeah
Queen C it could move
maybe rook rook d3 multi-purpose maybe
doubling up or maybe preparing the rook
lifts
I think rook III would have run into
this move I mean though g4 still
possible Knight g4 Queen f4 and blocks a
little bit tied down like the knight is
kind of pinned h6 oh I'm so tempted to
just go crazy does it work I can
calculate their their their king h7
Bishop c2 so here here here probably
King h8 Queen f4 there's 97 takes it's
hard to judge let's do it
have some fun
I forgot to consider Knight g4
thankfully this is me don't want it just
as I was thinking about this like
realized it didn't work okay tough
finish my opponents
let's analyze though let's see if this
is sound there's only so much like you
can do to calculate precisely and deeply
in blitz so this is Smith morale yeah
I'd be curious what Esserman has
prepared against this after a six I'm
out of any prep but I assume castling
wait but Esserman plays rapid and
classical so I could filter this a
little bit yeah so master of mayhem but
maybe he hasn't had this exact position
okay any master's games no let's just
look at the sack takes h6 I think black
should test me in this I was gonna play
rook g3 I don't think this is useful
because I get in the free tempo so this
and then this was forcing threatening
made into so I would imagine Knight h7
and then I was gonna take now
threatening rook h3 also ideas of this
I calculated through rook g8 and saw I
didn't see a clear win actually but I
saw there's still some pressure but
maybe blacks just surviving any Bishop C
to f5 work h 3 work g7 I throw punches
lock defends and blacks just up apiece
I'll check with stockfish but I'm not
seeing like massive initiative for
whites could be wrong stockfish finds a
draw
o stock fish likes White's so what's
wrong with this takes g8 6200 bishop
takes off 5 Wow let's only move as a
blind spot
I sure how about this this rook is
useful that's nice so white just keeps
attack on each 7 takes and then this Wow
very nice just meet next move ok so I
guess it all kind of worked so in this
position black has to be careful I was
thinking Knight g4 but it's tricky
I'm Bishop c6 hawkish knows best
ok one more game Joel Penn this will be
my 10th game that's a nice number to end
with hollow to real lift alright let's
play let's play d5 play a qgd
[Music]
I'll play a semi Slav this is actually a
mainline like usually black lacy six and
then white plays e3 but it's a
transposition o alpha zero knows best
because it's true but sock fish knows
better than most all people Bishop d2
all right I'll just develop I think the
plan is to castle and then eventually
break with e5 yeah just simple improving
moves now do I play e5 first let's do it
I want to make the bishop happy so this
is a one like bad piece in this like
initial structure so usually to make the
bishop happy you either play e5 or like
this and eventually c5 and the drawback
is white could maybe give me an i QP
it's like takes takes not the end of the
world
I'm okay with this it's double-edged
White's pawn structure is arguably
better but black has more space slightly
more active pieces to check out
booga-booga welcome back we also have
evil-minded
and this some founder Oney
I'll come back and Queen b3 what to do
I was some pressure
[Music]
the tricky move 94 this is typical move
when you have iqp just to expand there's
a tactical threat with this move I need
to take and when the bishop there's also
I mean there's also traps where if like
grabs a pawn then why gets punished
I think Eric do you want a solid I have
this move let's do this move if anything
have to lights are doing work kind of
just ignoring defending this pawn
actually have white takes I can I was
thinking some tactic with Bishop takes
h2 maybe it doesn't quite work
[Music]
so yeah there's not too many ways for
white to defend I mean if this move then
this smooth and I'll attack the knight
and win h2 there's this move yeah that's
probably the best move so if I take H -
hmm probably doesn't work play Bishop e6
just gambling this pawn but if white
takes I can maybe when B to get more
initiative looks nice the radicand
although okay let's do let's do this
yeah so I'm attacking like from multiple
directions there's a lot of like tender
pressure points
the Queen's on a seven kind of out of
play looks nice
also a nice time advantage to h3 okay
putting me to the test I mean there's so
much to look for here I have multiple
different captures or sacks I want to
take here and when e two of my nights
hanging there's Bishop here questioning
the Queen
there's taking f2
which also looks fun and there's simple
like Knight f6 I might just be simple
there's also a Bishop b8 also this moved
to so many choices let's just be simple
didn't want to spend all my time there
some idea of doing this and then this
and then threading mate hmm I could take
on c3 this is actually really
complicated
well a rookie sudden rookie savin's
simple just saving the rook attacking
the Queen Queen has to move somewhere
Queen feels almost trapped
I could take I'm winning a piece I can
take here I'll win the bishop
[Music]
yeah that is a complex position the
light had perhaps a bit too many targets
to worry about I wanna do this move but
no need let's do this move hmm
all of things clustered in the center
another sub wax pumpkin thanks for
solving a fitting name for the season
all right good game gel pen analysis
board tournaments are now wait go back
[Music]
so yeah first of all first of all Bishop
d2 not the most useful move
maybe it's anticipating some pin but
it's better to develop the kingside
first because sometimes a bishop goes to
be two or sometimes the bishop like just
doesn't develop until white plays d4
then it develops this way so we had
interesting position come Negi four is
the first I think critical moment do I
have Halloween plans maybe to host a
thematic Halloween gambits arena we'll
see but I don't really plan on dressing
up I was thinking about buying a green
shirt and then wearing it and then my
head will just be floating because of
green screen so we'll see I'll have to
find a green shirt yeah I'm just gonna
check with stockfish Black's doing well
so 94 the best move that's up there oh
did I miss something
take stakes oh I missed something I
could have taken all that would have
been nice and then I checked I went off
too and then probably rook lift rook e6
maybe in a longer game they've had time
to calculate thoroughly I need a green
share to okay well this has been an
interesting stream played ten games all
of which are added to the study maybe
I'll do another extreme like this and
just continue with this study
I'll build up my collection of
subscriber challenge games like a leaf
thanks for the bits I appreciate that so
yeah I need I need food also need some
rest
stay tuned for more chess content I
posted a video this afternoon just a few
hours ago part 1 of the autumn marathon
a lot more YouTube content in the
pipeline our next stream might be
tomorrow might do some collaboration too
very soon with a grandmaster it's you so
stay tuned for that how spooky is a
Halloween gambit will have to wait till
until Halloween to find out